Imagine, for a moment, that you are a teenager.
According to our viewership analytics, some
of you watching this won’t have to imagine
very hard, but some of you will have to really
stretch your mind to remember what that time
was like.
Either way, put yourself in the shoes of an
adolescent for a little while.
You’re anxious and uncomfortable in your
body, desperately trying to juggle your responsibilities
at school, your burgeoning sense of young
adulthood, your social life, the looming specter
of the future, and a dozen other things that
might make you stress-sweat through your hoodie.
Somehow, in between the classes and extracurriculars,
the standardized tests, and missed party invites,
you found someone who wants to go out with
you.
You’re not sure what they see in you, but
they must see something.
Several months into the relationship, you
decide to try and take things to the next
level.
You wait for your parents to leave town, you
pick out the perfect Netflix and Chill material,
dim the lights, and cozy up together on the
couch.
You go in for the kiss, and shockingly, it
goes over well!
Then, just when things are starting to heat
up, something doesn’t feel quite right.
You feel an overwhelming pain wash over your
body, there is a flash of blinding bright
light that burns into your retinas, and everything
goes black.
When you finally wake up, your partner is
gone, only a grisly smear of dark blood remaining,
staining the couch where they sat like some
kind of gory chalk outline.
Somehow, you know: they’re gone, they’re
never coming back, and it is all your fault.
It sounds like the opening scene of a horror
film, but for one unfortunate young man known
as SCP-213, it was all too real.
SCP-213 was recovered by the SCP Foundation
in Palo Alto, CA after his arrest.
The local police department brought him in
on charges of homicide after he accidentally
“vaporized” his girlfriend.
There were undercover Foundation agents in
the Palo Alto police department who, recognizing
this case as evidence of an anomaly, made
a report and were ordered to bring the boy
in for containment.
During the initial attempts to apprehend 213,
he vaporized the agents as soon as they made
physical contact with him.
Four agents were lost before 213 could be
successfully brought into a Foundation facility
where his anomalous properties could be better
studied.
SCP-213 is able to sever the bonds between
atoms in any solid matter he comes into physical
contact with.
During this process, there is a bright flash
of light, and SCP-213 experiences extreme
pain, often to the point of passing out.
Like most sentient beings in containment,
he is considered a Euclid class SCP.
SCP-213 was initially contained within a high-security
cell in Site-77.
The cell is surrounded by a 10-meter-wide
zone pumped full of gasses that are corrosive
to human skin.
SCP-213 was informed of the nature of his
containment.
Outside of the containment unit, two armed
guards were stationed with high-pressure hoses,
pepper spray, and polymer web grenades in
case of any escape.
However, containment of 213 soon proved difficult,
thanks to the nature of his seemingly uncontrollable
ability.
213 made seven escape attempts before one
was eventually successful.
He requested an interview with the researcher
assigned to his case, knowing that, when she
entered his containment facility, the containment
procedures would be temporarily disengaged.
He vaporized the remaining containment measures
and escaped from his holding cell.
The head researcher attempted to grab him
by the arm, but was promptly vaporized, dissolving
into a pile of blood and tissue.
Two more agents, who tried to block 213’s
path without touching him, met similar fates.
After making his way into the hall, 213 quickly
became disoriented, his mind muddled from
a mixture of pain, panic, and lack of familiarity
with the layout of the facility.
He was unable to find an exit and was cornered
in the staff break room, the door barricaded
with a chair, where he was attempting to vaporize
a portion of the floor.
At this point, he was too exhausted to disintegrate
any more matter, and collapsed from exhaustion
just as a group of agents broke down the door.
He was, with a great deal of care and the
use of a gurney to avoid any unnecessary physical
contact, returned to his original containment
cell.
Several weeks later, SCP-213 breached containment
again.
However, this time, it was completely unintentional.
Security camera footage from 3:15 AM on the
day in question showed 213’s bed and a portion
of the floor vaporize in a flash of light,
after which he fell through the opening in
the floor and landed in the basement.
This incident made it clear that 213 had far
less control over his ability than previously
believed.
Rather than a purposefully destructive entity,
he was simply a kid who destroyed what he
touched, and could not do anything about it.
If it could happen accidentally this time,
when else could it happen?
Could he, potentially, someday vaporize himself
without meaning to?
Following this containment breach, and some
time to recuperate from the injuries he sustained
from his fall, 213 offered to be more cooperative
with the research into his condition.
He agreed to comply with a series of experiments
as well as routine physical examinations,
and whatever else it might take to unlock
the secrets of the vaporization effect.
Just like the Foundation, he wanted to know
why he caused this destruction, and how he
could stop it from happening.
During one of the agreed-upon physical examinations,
the research team discovered something concerning.
There were smooth nodules, growths of abnormal
tissue, on 213’s back placed in the shape
of a perfect uare, with exactly 15 centimeters
between each one.
The nodules were determined to not be tumors,
or cancerous in any way.
They did not seem to cause the subject any
pain, and he could not remember how long they
had been there.
Perhaps they had been there his entire life.
Nothing resembling the nodules, or their precise
placement, could be found in any public medical
records or research journals.
It became clear that these strange spots on
213’s back were, likely, somehow related
to his anomalous ability.
Medical personnel were assigned to monitor
213 in his containment and watch for any changes,
and follow-up examinations were scheduled
to keep an eye on the nodules and any other
potential physical symptoms.
A week after the discovery of the first four
nodules, 213 was brought back into the examination
room for a follow-up inspection.
There was nothing new found on the subject’s
back, the original nodules remaining in their
place and exhibiting no change in size or
shape.
However, upon inspection of his hands, the
research team discovered two more nodules.
When asked if he was experiencing any pain
or discomfort as a result of these nodules,
213 insisted that he only felt some mild itching
and irritation on the skin around them.
A doctor pressed gently on one of the nodules
with his fingertips, and it did not budge.
With the appearance of these additional lumps
on 213’s hands, the research team opted
to perform a biopsy of one of them and extract
a sample.
A local anesthetic was administered to 213’s
left hand, and the doctor attempted to slice
into the surface of the nodule with a scalpel.
As soon as the scalpel’s blade came into
contact with his skin, there was a sizzling
sound, a blinding flash, and, when the attending
researchers had regained clear vision of the
room, the scalpel had disappeared.
SCP-213 insisted that he had not deliberately
vaporized the scalpel, and offered to try
again.
The second scalpel met the same fate as the
first, as did a third and then a fourth scalpel.
After the fifth scalpel disappeared, testing
was suspended for the day and 213 was sent
back to his containment chamber to rest for
the next day’s testing.
From that day on, 213’s demeanor changed.
He was less enthusiastic about continuing
to research his condition, complaining of
a pervasive sense of exhaustion no matter
how much he slept, ate, or hydrated.
He complained of extreme pain in his back
and stomach, which did not respond to treatment
with physical therapy or painkillers.
In spite of 213’s newfound apathy, the research
team was determined to persist.
They had come this far in their quest to uncover
the mysteries of SCP-213, and they were not
about to let their subject’s discomfort
- and a few lost scalpels - stop them now.
The plans for another follow-up exam and a
new attempt to perform a biopsy were cut short
when 213 was spotted via security camera having
a seizure in his containment cell.
He was moved to intensive care and kept there
for further observation.
Over the course of the previous 48 hours,
ten more nodules had appeared on his back.
Each separated by a distance of 5 centimeters,
the nodules formed no discernible pattern.
Once stabilized, 213 was returned to his cell,
where more medical personnel were stationed
alongside the guards, in order to monitor
his condition and watch for any further seizures
or other adverse effects.
One week later, everything would change, and
the true nature of SCP-213 would finally be
revealed.
213 requested his next physical exam, claiming
that he had noticed something wrong with him
while taking a shower.
While washing his back, he was shocked to
find the skin suddenly smooth and unblemished.
The nodules had disappeared, seemingly overnight.
However, he was more concerned than relieved.
He could not shake the feeling that, even
though he could not see it, something worse
had replaced them.
A cursory examination could not identify anything
in place of the nodules.
However, a closer inspection revealed that
there was indeed something there.
Where there had once been lumps of tissue,
there were now thin cuts, like surgical incisions,
less than one millimeter in width.
Guards rushed to the examination room when
the sound of a terrified scream echoed through
the halls.
There, they found the medical examiner, white
as a sheet and trembling.
While she had been examining the incisions
on 213’s skin, the one on his left palm
had opened to reveal an eye.
Though she could not explain how, she knew
that the eye was watching her, that it could
see what she was doing and wanted to understand
it.
213 was permanently transferred to the medical
wing of the facility, and placed under constant
observation.
The appearance of this eye sparked a new hypothesis
among the research team: SCP-213’s anomalous
properties are not his own.
Indeed, his body is not his own either.
Some sort of parasite is residing within him,
watching his surroundings through eyes buried
beneath the skin.
It is vaporizing matter in an attempt to protect
itself from harm, and possibly as a means
of feeding itself.
When the eye first appeared, and the parasite
hypothesis was introduced, SCP-213 began to
panic.
He begged the research team to remove the
parasite from his body, to cut him open and
extract it by any means necessary.
They refused, and 213 had to be sedated in
order to keep him from attacking any of the
medical staff.
Whatever is living inside of 213, it does
not show up on medical scans.
It cannot, or will not, communicate with the
research team about its nature, or what it
might want.
The more the medical team tests on it, the
larger it seems to grow, with more and more
tiny incisions appearing on 213’s body,
through which the entity can look.
SCP-213 has been placed in a medically induced
coma until the parasitic entity can be better
understood, and perhaps even removed from
his body.
In the meantime, perhaps it is better for
him, and every living thing around him, if
he just stays asleep.
Now go check out “SCP-426 - I am a Toaster”
and “SCP-999 - The Tickle Monster” if
you’re in the mood for some SCPs that are
more silly than scary!